і
сьогодні стоїть перед реальною загрозою
у
загрожує вторгнення російських військ
А ми бачимо
руйнацію в у нашої енергетичної
Незалежності
у глибоку економічну кризу в країні коли
навіть такі стратегічні підприємства які
забезпечують українців українців хлібом
можуть сьогодні зупинитись
і наша країна на кроків жаль
а залишається лідером в
у і в Європі і в світі
смертності в
у відкриту
і на цьому фоні ми спостерігаємо в у
бездіяльності української влади як в
питаннях захисту України таких питаннях
забезпечення
енергетичної
економічної безпеки наших громадян
о.в.
а напроти жаль замість того щоб в
і мобілізувати нас для того що б
І направити силові структури на боротьбу
проти
у російських провокації проти російської
агресії
ми спостерігаємо свами що саме
Завадський та його команда а
і скеровують силові структури на
боротьбу з політичної опозиції і в першу
чергу на боротьбу з
лідерами української опозиції
європейської солідарності
і безпосередньо зі головою Петром
Порошенком
що лідерів якась солідарності Петро
Порошенко
збирається виїжджати на заздалегідь
заплановані зустрічі
з-за вселенським патріархом а також з
європейськими лідерами які будуть
відбуватися в
у і саме враховуючи цю ситуацію Вони
почали брудне шоу яке називалась в
і негайне вручення
черговою повістки Петро Порошенко на
чергу в
Я хочу нагадати що ми друзі чи починаючи
з першого дня перебування завадського на
посаді Він розпочав
системну боротьбу проти 5 президент
І саме за його прямими вказівками
були сфабриковані сотні
кримінальних справ проти Петра Порошенка
в
а він отримав сотні приріст провів
багато годин на в
на допитах в різних структур
у і вже пройшло фактично два
і всі ці справи
перетворилися на фіг так само як і
перетворюються на чергова в у облікова
справа за прямою вказівкою чином
президент
йдеться про
забезпечення в
в Україну в з вугіллям і
а в умовах
у військового протистояння
2014 15 років
і так ситуація тоді була складною
у бо реально військово загострення
у і цих умовах тодішнє керівництво
України
змогло забезпечити енергетичну безпеку
не змогло дати тепло в оселі українців
тою складною небезпечною
14-15 років в
у ванні свояки залежні підконтрольні
люди
розповідають про підозру цій
забраковані справі
це виглядає особливо цинічно на фоні
того що за два останніх роки в
а Україна з
з якої
і стоїть Зеленський в
у і його команда а
Я повністю зруйнували енергетичну
безпеку нашої держави то саме
енергетичну безпеку який забезпечив
президент Порошенка та уряди
п'ятнадцять шістнадцять Сімнадцять
вісімнадцять дев'ятнадцять роках коли
країна не купувала російська вугілля
коли країна не купувала російський газ
то зараз зараз в умовах по цього
блюзнірство цього фарсу Україна за два
останніх роки купила
на 3 млрд 100 мільйонів доларів
російського вугілля в тому числі вугілля
яке ми законам Видобувається на
окупованих територіях
і це відбувається в умовах коли щодня
України збільшує обсяги
експорту в
у Білорусі в Україну електроенергій
в умовах коли Білорусь разом з
Російською Федерацією
робить заяви які погрожують національної
безпеки нашої держави і територіальній
цілісності
А я хочу сказати в
у
чинній владі й
І що ж
Я сподіваюсь
о.в.
а після проведення
запланованих міжнародних зустрічей так
коротко відпустки Петро Порошенко
повернеться в Україну в
у і ваша в
у чергова справа
А ваше чергове брудне шоу Як і всі
попередні
знову перетворюється на фарс і
Я хочу підкреслити що навіть повністю з
і залежна від
Генеральний прокурор
не
підписали в
у цей віковий документ
ти мені писала цю підозру а її підписав
сам або цією метою і призначений
попадинець їх заступників як мені
сказала на прізвище
Симоненко в
А ви знаєте надприбутків жаль цих
складних умовах в
а чинна Влада чинний президент в
Я повністю копіюють
Януковича в
у і його режим в
А як зрадницьки позиції щодо захисту
України
і так і в боротьбі з політичними
опонентами
А ви знаєте вони копіюють
їх брудні технології
і вони повністю повторюють і фінал
Янукович і його режим
о.в.
і питання а